All right.
So by last Friday we discovered
the electron,
discovered the nucleus.
And the problem then was how to
describe the structure of the
atom.
They knew there was an
electron, they knew there was a
nucleus, but exactly how did the
electron and the nucleus hang
together?
And we talked about how the
scientists at that time proposed
a classical model where the
interaction between the electron
and the nucleus was,
of course, the Coulomb
interaction, but where the
equations of motion were
Newton's equations of motion to
describe this electron going
around the nucleus,
F equals ma.
And, although we didn't show
it, what we said was that if we
used that force field,
the Coulomb force,
coupled with Newton's equations
of motion.
And, actually,
you also have to couple them
with some classical
electromagnetism,
which I may not have said but
which isn't important.
But if you use those classical
ideas to describe how that
electron goes around that
nucleus, well,
you would find that in 10^-10
seconds, that electron would be
on top of the nucleus.
And you would no longer have
what we know to be the structure
of the atom, in the sense that
you would no longer have some
volume where the diameter of
that volume is on the order of
an angstrom or so.
The bottom line is that these
classical ideas,
classical mechanics and
classical electromagnetism just
totally fail to explain the
structure of the atom.
And that was the conundrum that
the scientists faced in 1911.
This was quite a big problem
for the scientific community and
was so for about 10,
12, 13 years.
And, of course,
what fails are the classical
equations of motion,
Newton's equations.
A new kind of mechanics is
going to have to be invented in
order to understand how that
atom is bound or how the
electron and the nucleus are
bond, how it's stable.
But now, historically,
the actual clues for why the
electron didn't collapse into
the nucleus.
Those clues actually came from
a very different area of
discussion, and that area of
discussion is this wave particle
duality of light and matter.
It was certainly long believed
that matter, with its
particle-like behavior,
was distinct from light,
which was this kind of
transmission of energy through
space.
But in the late 1800s and early
1900s, there began to be made
some observations that seemed to
suggest that well,
you know, maybe this boundary
between matter and its
particle-like behavior and light
and its wave-like behavior,
well, maybe that boundary
wasn't so rigid after all.
And, in fact,
what we're going to see is that
radiation or light exhibits both
wave-like behavior and
particle-like behavior.
And it depends on the kind of
experiment that you do,
which one of those properties
you see, and that consequently
matter also exhibits both
particle-like behavior and
wave-like behavior.
And, again, it depends on the
particular experiment that you
do as to which one of those
properties you actually observe.
What we are going to do right
now is we're actually going to
set aside the discussion of the
structure of the atom,
how the electron and the
nucleus are bound together,
how in the world do they remain
stable?
We are going to set that
discussion aside,
and we are not going to pick it
up until next Monday.
And the reason for it is
because in order to proceed with
that discussion,
we actually have to go through
this other set of observations,
this discussion about the wave
particle duality of light and
matter in order to get the
clues, in order for us to make
progress about what next big
leap we've got to make in order
to talk about the structure of
the atom.
We are going to change
subjects, or it's going to look
like we're changing subjects,
but we're going to use the
results of our discussions in
the next three days to come back
to talk about the structure of
the atom.
Then the first thing we've got
to talk about is we're going to
talk about light and we're going
to talk about the wave-like
nature to radiation.
And since that is really
probably most intuitive,
let's do that.
Properties of waves.
Well, what are waves?
Well, you are familiar with
that.
Waves are a periodic variation
of some quantity.
In the case of water waves,
we have the periodic variation
of the height of water.
At some points in space here,
the height of the water is
high, at some point the height
of the water is low,
and there is some average level
here.
A sound wave.
Well, a sound wave is a
periodic variation of the
density of air.
At some points in space,
the air is very dense,
at other points in space the
air is not so dense,
and then there is an average
level here.
Well, what we're going to do is
we're going to set this average
level here to a zero.
And then, consequently,
our waves are going to have a
positive amplitude that is
measured from this zero level
up.
That's a positive amplitude.
And measured from zero level
down, that's our negative
amplitude.
These waves are going to have
positive and negative amplitude.
That is going to be very
important in how they actually
behave.
Now, what we're going to do,
oh, so what is light?
Well, light is a periodic
variation of an electric field.
And that is what I plot here.
Electric field versus distance.
And you can see,
it is varying in intensity.
But what exactly is an electric
field?
Well, let's just think about
that for a moment.
Suppose I take two parallel
plates, here is one and here is
another, and I am going to put a
negative potential on that top
plate and a positive potential
on the bottom plate.
And what is operating then
between this negatively charged
plate and the positively charged
plate is the Coulomb
interaction.
And the electric field then is
the space through which that
Coulomb force operates.
So, that electric field here is
this space through which this
Coulomb force is operating.
And, by convention,
we are going to say that it is
operating here in this
orientation.
In other words,
if I put a positive charge in
between these two plates,
in this electric field,
this space through which the
Coulomb force is operating,
well, what's going to happen is
that this positive charge is
going to drift to the negatively
charged plate.
But if I turn the geometry
around, if I put the negatively
charged plate on the bottom
using this coordinate system.
And I now put that positive
charge in that electric field,
it's going to drift to the
negatively charged plate again,
but it's going to move in this
coordinate system down.
So, this electric field has not
only magnitude because you can
imagine, the larger the
potential difference between
these two plates,
the larger the magnitude of the
electric field.
But that electric field also
has direction.
It is pointed in one way or the
other.
And that is what represented
here on my diagram of the
electric field versus distance.
You can see that right here,
the electric field,
the magnitude of it starts out
small, it increases,
continues to increase until we
get a maximum,
and then it starts getting
smaller.
It gets smaller and goes all
the way to zero,
at which point then it turns
around and the magnitude begins
to increase in the opposite
direction.
And, again, it becomes a
maximum in the opposite
direction and then turns around
and goes to zero and continues.
So, it's a periodic variation
here of an electric field.
And so what that means is that
if we put some charge,
say, at this point in space,
it will be pulled one way.
And if we put it at this point
in space, it will be pulled yet
another way.
And if we put it right here at
zero, it's not going anywhere.
Now, what I've shown you here
is a periodic variation of an
electric field.
It is also the case that
whenever we have an electric
field, we also have a magnetic
field that is actually
perpendicular to this electric
field here.
But since that magnetic field
is going to have all the same
characteristics as the electric
field, from our point of
discussion here,
I am not going to talk about
it, but you are going to see
this a lot next semester in
8.02.
So, we are just going to
characterize here the electric
field.
And the way we're going to
characterize it is to put a
functional form to it.
I am plotting the electric
field here as a function of x.
And the functional form that we
are going to use to characterize
it is A times cosine (2 pi x
over lambda),
a cosine function.
Now, what I want you to notice
is that this field oscillates
between a positive amplitude A
This coefficient right out in
front, right here,
that coefficient physically is
the maximum amplitude.
So, if you were to be given a
waveform that has a number out
here in front of a cosine x,
that number,
immediately the physical
significance of it is that it's
the maximum amplitude.
The other parameter besides the
amplitude here,
the maximum amplitude that we
use to characterize this cosine
function, is the wavelength.
The wavelength is the distance
between two successive maxima or
two successive minima.
And that wavelength here comes
in the argument of that cosine
function.
Again, if you were to be given
a form that had a number times
cosine times a number times x,
well, that number is equal to 2
pi over lambda.
And so almost by inspection,
you can figure out what the
wavelength is just from the
functional form of that cosine
function.
And because the argument is 2
pi x over lambda,
well,
you can easily see that you get
the maximum amplitude A here
whenever x is an integral
multiple of lambda.
When x is lambda,
2 lambda, 3 lambda or minus
lambda, minus 2 lambda,
or zero.
Most of that,
I think, you're familiar with.
But not only is light,
or formally,
electromagnetic radiation,
simply a periodic variation of
the electric or magnetic field,
but light is also a period
variation in time.
That is, light propagates,
it moves.
For example,
here is a cosine functional
form at some snapshot in time,
t equals 0.
And I put a star here on the
maximum of one of these maxima.
Now, what happens is that this
wave moves.
It propagates.
And the time it takes that wave
to move one wavelength,
just like it did in that very
short clip, --
-- the time it takes to move
one wavelength so that this
maxima that was here is now
there, is what we call a period.
One period is the time it takes
the wave to move one wavelength.
And we can also characterize
the period by the frequency of
the wave.
That frequency is nu, here,
and the period is 1 over.
And the frequency,
then, is the number of cycles
per second.
In other words,
if I were sitting right here at
x equals 0,
and I am just watching the wave
come by me, the frequency is the
number of times that a maxima
passes by me per second or the
number of times a minima passes
by me per second.
That is the frequency.
I will make that a little bit
more obvious in just a moment.
Frequency, I said,
is the number of cycles per
second.
But the unit that we use to
convey frequency is something
called the Hertz,
Hz.
And formally it is just inverse
seconds.
We drop the number of cycles,
but the number of cycles in
that unit is implied.
Now suppose the following.
I said that this electric field
has magnitude and it also has
direction.
Suppose I take an electric
field or an electromagnetic
radiation that has a frequency
of 1 Hz, one cycle per second.
And right here at x
equals zero, somehow I pin an
electron right there.
It cannot move anywhere.
It's just stuck.
What is going to happen to that
electron as this radiation of
one Hertz passes by?
Well, what's going to happen is
that that electron is going to
be now, since it's starting at
the top, it is going to be
pulled down.
And then it is going to be
pushed back up to its original
position every one second
because this frequency here is
one Hertz and because
this electric field has both
magnitude and it has direction.
Now, we're going to let this
electric field go by,
the electron gets pushed down
and pulled back up once every
second.
Hopefully that makes the idea
of frequency a little bit more
real to you.
Not only do we have this
periodic variation in time,
but we also have the wave
propagate here in space.
That wave moves this way or
this way or this way.
And so what we want to know is
the speed of that propagation.
Now, speed is always distance
traveled over the time elapsed.
And what we have already seen
is that this wave will move by
one wavelength in the time
period of a period.
That is, we already saw that
this wave will move here one
wavelength, from here to here,
in the time period of a period
or 1 over nu.
That's the time elapsed.
So the speed of this
propagation, the speed with
which it's moving,
is the distance traveled,
which is lambda divided by the
time elapsed,
which is 1 over nu.
And, therefore,
the speed of that propagation
is lambda times nu.
These are the important
concepts here.
We have the speed of the
propagation, lambda times nu,
we characterized our wave in
terms of amplitudes,
in terms of wavelengths and in
terms of frequency.
Those are the quantities that
are important that you really do
have to understand very well.
Now, I think that you are all
familiar with the fact that all
electromagnetic radiation has a
constant speed.
That is, the wavelength of
electromagnetic radiation times
its frequency is always equal to
this number.
It's about 3x10^8 meters per
second.
And we abbreviate it c,
the speed of light.
No matter what frequency you
have of radiation,
the corresponding wavelength is
such that the wavelength times
the frequency is this constant,
is this value of c.
And, of course,
it is the different frequencies
or the different wavelengths of
electromagnetic radiation that
gives it its different
characters, --
-- even though it all has the
same speed of propagation.
And those different kinds of
properties, so to speak,
are this spectrum of
electromagnetic radiation.
So electromagnetic radiation is
an infinitely wide spectrum.
At very long wavelengths,
we have what are known as radio
waves.
At very short wavelengths,
we have what are known as gamma
rays or cosmic rays.
The long wavelengths,
the radio waves,
are going to have a relatively
low frequency.
The short wavelengths are going
to have a relatively high
frequency.
Why?
Because the product of lambda
times nu always has to be c.
Well, we're not going to go
very much in detail here,
except maybe to tell you the
following.
See this microwave range here?
Well, molecules,
when they absorb microwave
radiation, they rotate.
See the infrared radiation?
When molecules absorb infrared
radiation they vibrate.
See the visible and ultraviolet
range?
When molecules absorb visible
or UV radiation,
they put an electron into a
higher energy state.
And oftentimes,
once you do that,
of course, the electron wants
to relax to a lower energy
state, and so it relaxes by
emitting a photon.
And that's how you see
fluorescence or phosphorescence.
But it's usually a result of
the absorption of visible or UV
radiation.
Although, it is also possible
for a molecule to absorb some
X-ray radiation and see that
kind of fluorescence,
too.
And we will talk about it.
But a little bit later on we're
going to talk about molecules
absorbing X-ray radiation and
kicking out an electron.
And we are going to use that to
figure out how strongly bound
electrons are in atoms or how
strongly bound they are in
molecules.
But that is all I will say
about that right now.
What you are responsible for
is, --
-- you are responsible in
knowing that microwaves have
longer wavelengths than gamma
rays or cosmic rays.
You are responsible for knowing
the relative wavelengths here of
these different kinds of
radiation.
Every MIT student should know
that.
Of course, there is a very
narrow range here of visible
radiation that our eye is
sensitive to.
At the very long wavelengths is
red.
At the very short wavelengths
is blue and purple.
Again, you need to know that
red has a longer wavelength than
blue or purple.
What I have done right now is
really just to tell you that
light is an electromagnetic
radiation characterized at the
wave.
I put a functional form to it,
cosine, characterized it by
frequency, wavelength.
We talked about speed of
propagation.
What I haven't done yet is I
haven't proved to you that light
is, in fact, or light behaves
like a wave.
And that is what we are going
to do now.
And the experiment we are going
to do is the same experiment
that a gentleman called Young
did in the late 1800s that
seemed to really demonstrate,
without a question,
that light is a wave,
or light behaves like a wave.
We are going to do what's
called the two-slit experiment.
And in this experiment,
we are going to take radiation
of a single wavelength,
so we're going to make the
radiation monochromatic.
And that wavelength that we are
going to use is 6,330 angstroms
or 633 nanometers.
And we are going to put in
front of that source,
we are going to put a thin
piece of metal,
or it could be any material,
but we are going to poke two
holes in it.
We're going to make two little
slits.
And naively,
what you might expect is,
if you have a screen back here
that kind of images this
radiation --
What you might expect is that
the spots on the screen right
directly opposite these two
slits, well, these are the two
spots that are going to light up
on the screen.
That is where you're going to
see the image because,
after all, light travels in
straight lines.
That's where you should see
those two spots.
If the slits here are 0.02
inches from each other,
these two spots ought to be
0.02 inches separated from each
other.
But, of course,
when you do that experiment,
and Christine is actually going
to do that experiment right now
for us, I think,
there it is,
on the side board.
You can sort of see it.
She is holding it.
Well, what you can see here is
that we don't see just two
bright spots.
But what we see is a bunch of
spots here.
The brightest one happens to be
right in the center of these two
slits.
And then there is darkness and
then there is a bright spot and
darkness, and a bright spot,
etc.
We see lots of different bright
spots on the screen,
not just two directly opposite
the openings of the slits.
And this is just then a cartoon
of approximately what it is we
see in real life.
Christine is up there in the
projection booth,
holding a helium-neon laser
behind these two slits separated
by 0.02 inches.
Well, what's going on here?
Can we understand what the
origin is of these lots of
different bright spots in this
two-slit experiment?
Actually, if we were to measure
that, the distance here should
be about 3 cm between those
bright spots.
Well, what's going on?
Well, what's going on is this.
Waves have the property called
superposition.
That is, if I take one wave,
but then I take a second wave
and I put that second wave in
the same space,
the actual same space as the
first wave, and I arrange the
two waves such that the maximum
of both waves or the minimum of
both waves is at the same
position, well,
the property of waves is that
these two waves add up.
They superimpose.
They superimpose to make a wave
that now has the amplitude of
twice the amplitude of each of
those waves.
And that is the condition that
we call constructive
interference,
but we have to have the two
waves at the same place in space
and the two maxima have to be in
the exact same place in space.
But conversely,
we can also take the wave and
bring in another wave,
but we can move that other wave
over such that the maximum of
one of the waves is at the same
place in space as the minimum of
the other wave.
In this case,
these two waves are out of
phase.
And when we add them up,
there will be nothing.
This is destructive
interference.
Why?
Well, because we have positive
amplitudes and negative
amplitudes.
They cancel to give us nothing.
Destructive interference.
And there is a website here at
the University of Colorado that
lets you take two waves and
superimpose them.
I need to play with it.
What I am going to do is I am
going to make it so that these
two waves have the same
frequency or the same wavelength
and the same amplitude.
What I am doing here is I am
adding this wave,
I am adding this wave right
here to this wave,
and the result is shown here.
And what you cannot see is that
the amplitude down here,
that amplitude is twice that of
these two.
There is a two there.
But, of course,
what I can do is I can move
this wave over such that the two
waves are now at the same place
in space, sort of,
where the maximum and the
minima are at the same place in
space and exactly cancel them.
And I am not having such a
great time doing this here,
but I know you can do it
because I have done it before.
And you can see that the
resulting amplitude is zero.
And, of course,
then you can go home and you
can play all you want with this,
make all kinds of different
waveforms.
I am trying to change the
amplitude here,
which I have done before,
but I cannot right now.
You can do whatever waveform
you want to.
You get the idea here with
superposition.
So, that's a characteristic of
waves.
They have positive and negative
amplitudes.
They add and they cancel
depending on the relative
positions in space.
But now, let's talk a little
bit more about this pattern that
we saw in the two-slit
experiment.
This kind of row of bright
spots.
And, to talk about it,
what we are going to do is
we're going to use water waves
to try to explain it.
Here is a picture of the beach.
Here is the water,
here is the sand,
and here is where I wanted to
be all weekend.
And the waves are coming in to
the beach.
These straight blue lines are
the crests of the waves rolling
into the beach.
And suppose I get ambitious and
I erect a barrier right here at
the shore, a sand barrier,
but for whatever perverse
reason I poke two holes in that
sand barrier.
Well, what is going to happen
as the waves roll up?
is that a little bit of the wave
here, this is kind of like a
pinhole, is going to leak
through.
When it leaks through,
it is going to spread out
equally in all directions.
And so the wave front is going
to look like this semicircle
here.
That is the wave crest.
It is going to look like a
semicircle.
And that is going to propagate
out.
And when it propagates out to a
distance of 2 lambda,
well, then another wave has
snuck in here through this hole
and it propagates out.
Again, the distance between
these two semicircles is a
lambda, is the wavelength,
because these are the maxima of
the two waves.
And, as time goes on,
that propagates further and
another wave sneaks through that
hole and another wave sneaks
through and the whole thing
propagates.
Meanwhile, while that is
happening, there is also a part
of the wave sneaking through
this hole and it emanates out in
all directions and propagates
out in all directions.
And let me, for the purpose of
talking about this,
call this slit slit 1.
All the green waves are the
waves that came through slit 1.
And I am going to call this
slit 2.
And all the blue waves are the
waves that came out slit 2.
And, again, the distance
between any of these two crests
is the wavelength.
And the wavelength is the same
for the waves coming from slit 1
and slit 2.
Now what I want you to do is I
want you look at this point
right here.
See that point?
Well, right at that point,
what we have is we've got the
wave crest, the wave maximum
from slit 2 at the same point in
space as the wave maxima from
slit 1.
If we've got two maxima at the
same point in space,
hey, we've got constructive
interference right there,
because those amplitudes are
going to add.
Look at this point.
Well, again,
we've got the wave maxima from
this blue wave coming through
slit 2 at the same point in
space as the wave maxima from
the wave coming from slit 1.
Again, this is a point of
constructive interference.
And we can keep going.
Again, we have two maxima right
here, a point of constructive
interference.
And, you know what,
everywhere along this line we
are going to have constructive
interference.
We are going to have a
resultant wave,
a water wave that is going to
be twice as high as each of the
individual waves.
Look at this.
What I want you to notice here,
for this point:
for this point,
the wave that is constructively
interfering, that has traveled
from the slit a distance
r two, because this is slit 2.
But the distance from here to
here is 4 lambda.
It is 1 lambda,
2 lambda, 3 lambda,
4 lambda, right?
The radius r two of this
circle is 4 lambda.
And it is interfering with this
wave crest.
And the distance that that wave
traveled from slit 1,
I am going to call r one,
and that is equal to 3
lambda, 1, 2,
3.
This interference here is
between this wave that has
traveled out a distance,
4 lambda, and this wave that
has traveled out a distance,
3 lambda.
And the difference in the
distance traveled by those two
waves that are constructively
interfering is 4 lambda minus 3
lambda equals 1 lambda.
Is there a question over here?
Yes?
I think I am coming to that.
That was a snapshot of the next
slide.
Sorry.
Yes?
Because we are treating these
as regular waves,
ordered waves.
Real waves on an ocean are not
like that.
And then, you won't see this
diffraction pattern that I am
erecting here.
But, if you had pretty regular
waves coming in,
in principle you could see it.
And I am going to show you,
in a tank, some water waves
that do just this.
Now I want you to look at this
point right here.
Right here we have a point of
constructive interference
because we have two maxima at
the same point in space.
And at this point we've got
constructive interference.
So everywhere along this line
here, we are going to have
constructive interference.
And now I want you to look at
the difference in the distance
of the waves that yield this
constructive interference along
this line.
I want you to look at this
green wave that is
constructively interfering with
this blue wave.
This green wave has traveled
out a distance r one or 2
lambda, and it is interfering
with this blue wave here that
has traveled out a distance 4
lambda, r two equals 4
lambda.
So, the difference in the
distance traveled for all of
these points that lead to
constructive interference,
the difference in the distance
traveled here is r two minus r
one or 4 lambda
minus 2 lambda equals 2 lambda.
Does that agree with the
snapshot in your picture?
Yes.
I just didn't show you the
other one.
Now I want you to look here.
Here is a point of constructive
interference.
Here is another point of
constructive interference.
Everywhere along this line we
are going to have constructive
interference.
And, if we check out what the
difference in the distance
traveled is between the waves
that are constructively
interfering there,
you are going to see that r two
minus r one is equal to 0.
Now, what you would predict is
we would have along this angle
some very bright spots,
along this angle some very
bright spots.
And along this angle some very
And you also can see that this
is going to be symmetric about
the center, so you would have
bright spots here,
bright spots there.
Well, let's look at this in
real life, in a water tank,
where we have plain waves
coming into a barrier and then
we have two little slits right
there and right there.
And what you can see is that
these bright semicircles are,
in fact, the crest of the
waves.
But what I want you to see is
right here --
What I want you to see,
is right here:
These are this bright row,
here is a bright row,
here is a bright row.
And in between there is kind of
just a muddy diffuse pattern.
Well, this diffuse pattern is
nothing.
This is a bright row.
You get the idea.
You are going to have an angle
which there is going to be
constructive interference,
several angles of which there
is going to be constructive
interference.
And in between those places
where there is constructive
interference,
there is destructive
and you are not going to have
any light.
How does that relate to what we
saw in the two-slit diffraction
experiment?
Along this line we have waves
that have constructively
interfered, and they
constructively interfere so that
on the screen right there you
have a bright spot.
And along this line,
the difference in the distance
traveled by the waves that
constructively interfere is 1
lambda.
And then we've got another row
or another line,
points of constructive
interference.
That is going to image as a
bright spot.
And if you analyze that,
the difference in the distance
traveled by these two waves is 2
lambda.
And then we're going to have
another bright spot here.
For all the constructive
interference along this line,
the difference in the distance
traveled is zero.
And, of course,
I said before this was
symmetric around the center.
And so this is what gives rise
to the different bright spots on
the screen when we did the
two-slit experiment.
Bright spot.
Dark spot.
The bright spots are
constructive interference.
The dark spots here are
destructive interference.
Now, let me just tell you that
the general condition for having
these bright spots --
The general condition that has
to obtain is that the difference
in the distance traveled has to
be equal to N,
an integer, times lambda.
This bright spot,
the difference in the distance
traveled, N is 0.
We call that the zero order
spot.
This bright spot,
the difference in the distance
traveled is lambda,
or N times lambda,
where N is 1,
first order interference
feature.
Here, the difference in the
distance traveled is 2 lambda,
N times 2, called the second
order interference features.
And the condition for that is
this, r2 minus r1 equals N times
lambda. There is
also a condition for destructive
interference,
which I ask you to think about,
and we will talk just briefly
about its origin next time.
All right.
See you on Wednesday.